não dá não dá a ninguém e mídia essa
prática e e pessoal de quem falar que
sejam muito bem vindos
é mais um euro e um estrago seguiu pois
esperei muito barça joga sua grade de
ferro é estar de volta logo eu não sei
nem inscrito como uma que este jogo ao
do sinait 762 e parecem ser um jogo
muito bom inclusive se inscrito disse
que o jogo sob escolta e estola e uma
arma estava com o fred vai aumentar o
volume de aproveitar tudo com uma
pistola e um dos vices já sabe que só se
quiserem outro tipo de jogo foi muito
feliz com o que tem embaixo eu sei eu já
vi por aí na internet que agora existe
um texto night ultimato lexton arde em
chamas
eu já tive investigar e parece muito
difícil e eu não sei se eu estou apto
para jogar esse jogo mas se quiserem ver
que no canal comentem mas se o bastante
o último não é fácil ver sofás ou pisar
em uma pizzaria
já no começo a rir porque eu sei que vão
gostar olha aí temos num armazém em uma
garagem
sério eu estou muito impressionado com
esta qualidade gráfica conheço este
técnica num dos dois jogos por esta luz
tem muita textura está muito bonito e já
nem sei quem é aquilo que o fred é que o
preço um pouco abordada na esteira do
porco no espeto por aí uma granada estou
grata será em granada a aten que o botão
é uma alavanca vai da costa vai vai
perceber que o fred vai fazer tudo aqui
eu já sei essas portas vão abrir mais
prazer que tudo tem quase certeza disso
mas vamos lá está hoje abre sempre tocou
lá é para lá por fora é que vão surgir
para isso conta que se discuta quebrada
mas não sabia isto isto abriu abriu
ontem a passagem aqui junto a um cão de
guarda foi max
o u 80 mil na minha mão de obra faz
sentido e odair discorda 0
eu não fui expulso nenhuma gangue girl
que na cabeça o outro um palco atrás uma
da manhã e duas da manhã já possui uma
hora muito rápido e agora com o dinheiro
do aluguel guerra muito novo e não sei
que é difícil eu não vou ter esta opção
eu dei perseguições pessoais hamilton
mas eu não sei se esconde não tem muita
opção não gosta sim não não para o
estudo da dor não vai aturar mata meu
deus meu coração agora vai
acho que há emissões é bom é isso mesmo
pouco então se não fique sem bala rocha
atua no campo
como assim agora só usuário não desfaz
inércia não ser um órgão do profissional
a não instalar o nelson lourenço rango é
um dos dois sistemas embala bêbado
deixa o cara está lá tome mais treinar e
eu explodi imposto mulheres têm muito
podre como se pode mais falar mas quem
são os cães e os demais campos volta pra
escola
deus é muito engraçado esse jogo é muito
engraçado pois está muito normal que o
carro tá na cabeça
não posso dizer os nerds a atmosfera de
frango e empatámos outra vez não pode
ser não arquiva cursor no silêncio da
noite
sou eu não quero chegar isto mas é muito
difícil e isso é a primeira noite eu
acho para time é esse e vai pôr-se em
fashion week
muitas pessoas na bahia numa ronda em
que 800 bala rocha é mó o outro é um
outro extremo sul é muito ou não não
posso ficar com meu filho
[Música]
matar não para todos minha casa eu vou
passar a noite
aí eu vou passar a noite em uma lei fico
até naquilo que seja melhor para as
empresas é que o senhor vai ser todo o
processo já olha para acabar o jogo pelo
jogo bonito mas eu fui eu disse não eu
já tô profissional
stallone passou o jogo já deu certo
ó eu já estou aguentando mais eu já nem
vitória aqui
mas há mais
mas não é nada mas a bala não vou morrer
pela bala
olha o tony hawk é muito da manhã
se bater tuuuudo nos vôos deu espaço eo
túnel do espaço casas históricas do
mickey
olha que ninguém olha que irritou as
outras lutas atrás de mim
como é que a gente espera que eles
tinham deixei muito laquê nos filho um
cãozinho já só uma da manhã e à noite
passaram a acontecer às 18 já era manhã
o sol já tinha por ciro e mesmo assim o
jogo não acabou
portanto eu não sei que hoje precisa
agüentar mais ver se fico umas dez
músicas da manhã e tinha procedido a um
monstro novo tocando não viaja por si um
coelho mole e parece uma represa na
muito animal aqui toda estava lá mais o
quê estava lá mais tarde no cursinho diz
a folha com um cãozinho eu fale muito
muito bem quando nunca posso fazer
[Música]
já no reino
eu sou mestre sul 2 x 6 meses e 2 anos
filha da mãe
o que quero é que o bicheiro bateu vamos
lá tentar outra mesma hora para lá
passar de 80 não sei se o tal jogo
última e3 fred espera na rede de
franquias na e que o pessoal anda a
jogar agora eu não sei se é mais
complicado que isso mas deve ser se
experimentar complicado imagina jogar
isso que vocês querem que o jogo
impossível não vai lá eu estou irão que
o royce um teste como é que vocês vêm
para teatro 25 de agosto no que ela nem
tudo é mau e
o oi iogues e pra onde eu consegui ouvir
o cão eo e silva
ae
tudo por tudo para que meu cérebro
essa exclusão é desnecessária e muito
necessário usar um produto para ver como
é que eu acho que há pouco não dá pra
passar mas já pensando meu deus do
futebol um de manejo até o bar já está
situado aí já produzimos o dae documento
cuja culpa do café etc
lula não tem nada não ficam assim como
eu não esqueço isso ai meu deus
de mais a mais quente com a cabeça dos
nikkeis e três na cabeça 4 330 cabeças
assim vou poupar muita bola com calma da
marca de 32 balázios microblog que já
foi tudo mais ainda mais a que mais
faltou sentir eu senti direito eu sei
direito que entrar determinados
alimentos a você e eu não mas quero
passar pelas quatro da manhã e agora vêm
à tona velhas
agora ele vem aqui com o mv an eye hell
morro a terceira velha
aproveitei tudo conhecer também é o
quase marcam 1 2 3 4
ao mesmo tempo ela
gera um número ruim já que isso eu seria
titular aí você estava à espera que eu
puder servir à aula lanã ou mais que o
que mais o que mais velho
olha olha que olhe mais para estupro
fama se e agora estou pronto a vocês
pela equipe médica a gente fica na sede
da urp mata tudo caraças chegou
a top vai andar tudo sua ser injusto que
pra mim estes tempos tem muito
confortável muito confortável a casa e
agora vou fazer um esforço para ficar
concentrado agora sim agora é cuidar
clássico assim aqui na área da cabeça
o carro como recado que classe
profissional deixando muito acho que não
acho nojento e na hora é agora
houve uma mini outra vez houve uma
criança eu acho que você não foi eu acho
que sim
[Música]
estou muito concentrado muito que estou
apto para ir para escola e estou apto
bem mais barata já esqueceu da onu
sou muito somados não vai mudar
- trago a opção muita gente que vai lá
também é o nosso também né
sou nova mulher velha natureza da mega
[Música]
sena vai por outro caminho mas é isso
pessoal espero fazer minha história aqui
dentro eu não vou tentar mais vítimas
não vou morrer aqui com um ataque de
coração e só se vocês forem novos aqui
no canal e inscreva-se deixei muito aqui
também e isso ajuda muito é que o canal
esquecer mais vídeos deste de terror
como tem muito em baixo e teve o voto
eu não vou voltar completamente oca eu
vou introduzindo assim os vídeos deste
número do meu conteúdo que eu gosto de
fazer mas quanto mais vocês comentarem
que querem terror mas eu posso dizer que
só pretende um estado fiquem até a
próxima